[Music]
my name is bjorn ranheim and i serve as
the music director for the world chess
hall of fame
concert series i have been affiliated
with the organization since 2016
so i'm in my fourth year so the world
chess hall of fame
like many other arts organizations
needed to make a very quick
pivot in order to continue to offer
cultural meaning to our community
and the world chess hall of fame concert
series has now gone
completely virtual for the time being
uh we are aided by wonderful support of
tim albert brian mateen and
charles babatu murphy and their team has
really helped us
to take our concert offerings onto
a much wider viewership and it's
actually been a wonderful
bomb during these very difficult times
and it's also been a wonderful
benefit to the musicians and performers
in our community
in still offering an outlet to perform
even though it's not for an in-person
audience
[Music]
the donations that come from the
strategy across the board
event are pivotal in all of the mission
that we try to accomplish here
we try to present musicians and
performers
from local and national scenes but we
want to bring
the highest quality events to
our audiences and without those
donations
we would not be able to do that so we
are able to have a very
highly regarded series here and it's
absolutely in part of all the generous
donations to the
program
[Music]
there are many incredible organizations
here in st louis
and we are lucky to partner with many of
them
in a lot of our concert offerings some
of those organizations
are the opera theater of st louis winter
opera of st
louis the chamber music project of st
louis there's many organizations that we
partnership with
to allow venues for their particular
type of cultural contribution
and to introduce our audiences to their
wonderful expertise and so we do that in
a number of ways
but it is really a joy of my position
here
in getting to connect our audiences with
a lot of different
uh cultural organizations throughout the
st louis region
[Music]
you